اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم في اليوم الدولي للتعليم
الامم المتحده تقول ان اكثر من
625 الف طالب في غزه محرومون من التعليم
وتؤكد تضرر
75% من المباني المدرسيه كما دعت الى وقف
الحرب في غزه والعوده الامنه الى التعليم
وتجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط
بالتعليق الاول بعد اعلان القوات
الامريكيه ضرب مواقع غرب العراق الحشد
الشعبي يعلن مقتل احد منتسبيه واصابه
اثنين والحكومه العراقيه تقول ان القصف
افعال عدوانيه وتتعهد باتخاذ الاجراءات
اللازمه تجاهها في حين قالت المقاومه
الاسلاميه انها هاجمت بمسيرات قاعده عين
الاسد التي تضم قوات
امريكيه مصدر عسكري يمني يؤكد استهداف
سفينه قرب باب المندب والبنتاجون يعلن
تدمير صارخ خين مضادين للسفن ويؤكد ان
الضربات ضد مواقع الحوثيين لن تكون لها
حاجه اذا اوقفوا الهجمات من جهته اكد
قيادي في الجماعه استمرار هجماتهم البحريه
طالما استمرت الحرب على غزه روسيا تعلن
تحطم طائره نقل عسكريه على متنها 65 جنديا
اوكرانيا اسيرا في منطقه بجرود وتتهم
اوكرانيا باسقاطه في حين قال مصدر في
الجيش الاوكراني للجزيره ان جميع من كانوا
على متن الطائره عسكريون روس الى
اللقاء